nathan is with us in indianapolis hi
Nathan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
sure how can I help
well this week everybody better to call
themself I am currently honors follow
your [ __ ] up can you speak directly
into it please sure let me is much
better thank you I am currently in sales
and trying to find out if it's a good
idea I'm looking at a possible career
change and changing from sales and to
public service as a police officer but
while I'm doing baby step two I'm trying
to see if that's a good idea as it would
be a volunteer program and would take in
the evening time up I would use to do
more sales and they offered that at the
time so okay how much debt do you have
right now it's roughly around ninety
seven thousand and what is it on we have
student loans collar emily has burden
Laura guard student loans is roughly
fifty thousand how much is the car 19
okay
and how much is the credit cards it
would be the remainder of it credit card
medical bill twenty-eight okay and what
do you make a year
right now it's around fifty thousand
myself and what would you make as a
police officer it would start about the
same okay and how long would it take you
to become a police officer the Reserve
Program is volunteer and it would take
them all
anywhere from 10 months to do the
training in evening times in weekends
and if I got picked up by the full time
that's what it would be fifty thousand
started first year ok I'm sorry so how
long would it be that you're giving up
your evenings two nights a week and then
two Saturdays a month on for how long
before you became a police officer about
ten months so ten months from the time
you started you'll be a policeman making
50k well it's a volunteer program that I
was trying to get at and so after that
how long after your reserve after ten
months now you get to work for free
right in the reserve day for how long
before you become a policeman they said
you can actually be picked up in the
process of becoming a reservist they
have a spot open they can pull you
straight from that so that's what they
can happen but that's not if they're
trying to get people to work for free so
when it went and what normally happens
and what's your worst case scenario how
long does is the worst case before they
pick somebody up
we don't know it's just whatever they
haven't given any direct answers but
they do have two openings at the police
department but it's a matter of right
now that the police Academy's kind of
backed up on their training - so okay
all right so you can do the police
academy training at night and on
Saturdays correct it well the Reserve
Program so it no I mean or neutering
let's say they hired you for one of
those two slots can you do the training
on nights and Saturdays or the reserve
you know those two slots are the two
slots reserve are they policemen the two
are active but those we don't know if
they're going to hire when they're going
to hire for this at this point so that's
the problem it would be reserved until
they okay decide they're gonna take
somebody over and how much do you make
extra by working at night and Saturdays
[Music]
right now that would be I have no
overtime option but I can be working on
proposals and stuff sent out if I do
that at night at home so how much is it
gonna cost you in money if you pursue
this thing in mr. honours that I'm not
sure that is the answer to your equation
okay if it's not gonna cost you anything
because you can work on the proposals
and stuff during downtime during the day
then you can go forward if it's going to
cost you $25,000 in miss sales no you
cannot go forward you need to stick with
it and clean this up for the base sake
of your family right so you need to
figure out what this is going to cost
you in lost sales to screw around with a
free reserve program that may or may not
result in you moving into the career
that you think you want okay so I'm with
you I think you need to make the move
that direction but we've got to do good
critical thinking and analyze okay I'm
giving up this but what I'm you know is
there a 90% chance I get picked up
during the time how quickly are they
going to activate these two slots that
are open and fund them with the budget
if so if they can hire you now subject
to you knocking out the police academy
and they'll pay you to go to the police
academy then you know go and just live
your life right because it's a
break-even and you get to do what you
love so I would do all of that but but
if you're gonna be you know jerking
around with this thing for three or four
years while they pull you along on a
string with a carrot you know and
someday well maybe when the budget
clears well maybe the reserves maybe not
we might hire a brother and all that
kind of garbage and it's gonna cost you
twenty five thousand dollars a year
while you're trying to get out of death
and no you don't need to do that so
there you go that's what I would do
thanks for calling in